كبرى دول البلطيق تتاهب للحدث
موعد مع الملح امامه من ملفات الساعه
سيناقش قاده دوله التزاما بزياده الانفاق
الدفاعي والاستثمار في القدرات العسكريه
ومن اولوياتهم ايضا تعزيز امن الجبهه
الشرقيه للحلف وقدراته في الردع والدفاع
لا يغيب عن جدول اعمال قمه فيلنيوس بالطبع
ما يوصف بالدعم غير المحدود لاوكرانيا في
حربها ضد روسيا غير ان الجدل المحيط
بالعضويات الجديده المحتمله في الحلف قد
يخطف الاضواء من الملفات كلها
ستحضر فنلندا القمه بوصفها الان عضوا في
النيتو اما جارتها السويد فقد اتفق
الامريكيون والبريطانيون عشيه القمه على
الحاجه الى ضمان ان لديها مسارا سريعا
للانضمام الكامل الى الحلف
وترى قياده الناتو ان السويديين استوفوا
بالفعل الشروط المطلوبه لذلك لانضمام لكن
انقره تعتقد ان احراز تقدم في عضويه
ستوكهولم التي سيحسمها البرلمان التركي
مرهون بتنفيذ ما تم التوصل اليه في اتفاق
مدريد الثلاثي
بل ان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يربط الان
قبول انضمام السويد لنيتو بتمهيد الطريق
لعضويه تركيا الكامله في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ليس للاسباب نفسها قد يؤجل تحقيق حلم
اوكرانيا الاطلسي على الارجح الى ما بعد
الحرب تتحمس لتلك العضويه دول شرق اوروبا
الاعضاء في الحلف بالاساس ويلمح الامين
العام للنيتو الى امكانيه تقليص المراحل
المطلوبه بنكييف لانضمامها المنشود لكن
يدرك هنا هواجس واشنطن واعضاء غربيين
اخرين ذلك ان ضم كييف الان للنيتو فيما
ترى اداره بايدن سيجعل الحلف في حاله حرب
مباشره مع روسيا روسيا التي تحذر من عواقب
وخيمه على الامن الاوروبي في حال ضم
اوكرانيا الى النيتو
ما يريده الرئيس الاوكراني الان من قمه
النيتو هي ضمانات الامنيه واضحه قبل
انضمام بلاده للحلف برلين تكشف ان
للامريكيين مقترحا في هذا الصدد
كما ذكرت مرارا وتكرارا لعده اشهر فاننا
نناقش مساله الضمانات الامنيه لاوكرانيا
بعد اتفاق السلام الذي نامله دائما هذه
مناقشه تجري بشكل مكثف للغايه ونشعر ايضا
اننا مضطرون الى ايجاد ضمانات امنيه
وكيفيه تنظيمها قيد المناقشه حاليا
الاقتراح الذي قدمه الرئيس الامريكي ليس
جديدا تماما لكنه يلعب دورا رئيسيا ويعطي
بعض المؤشرات على ما يمكن ان يكون لكن
النقاش لم ينتهي بعد لم ينتهي النقاش
وسيمتد الى قمه فيلينيوس من هناك ينتظر
الاوكرانيون اشاره ما اي اشاره من الشركاء
الغربيين